pogchamps 3 is brought to you by gaiuki as
gayaki celebrates 25 years of regenerative
yerba mate they want to thank you for being a
part of their mission achievement to steward
and restore over 200 000 acres of rainforest
come to life at gaia key dot com slash chess
hey hey still better than excuse me bad winner
bad winner ludwig is one killer keep it going
wait chess.com watching right now still
hi sweetie how's it going um i hope you cheer me
on in my match i love you and as per usual cutie
i didn't listen to a word that led had to say how
is he sound um how's he standing well typically
cocky overconfident and full of that's usually how
he's sounding but i don't know how he's sounding
today i haven't listened either oh they already
started they jumped in yeah but she could have
used your advice before this situation
happened because in the petrov after e4
the knight hits the pawn taking it you should
not take back you need to kick the knight first
before you take this pawn because of this exact
sequence if the knight moves out of the way
then white will have a discovery so if
the knight goes to f6 this knight moves
it's check on the king and knight c6 kicks
and you can't block that would be a loss there
uh-oh nico looks slightly confused and mikko's
yelling oh gosh my god feeling out of sorts
and
i don't know what to say
is mikko okay mikko miko's dealing with this on
an existential level and well love was thinking
ludwig almost looks frozen
he's thinking so hard right now
interesting moves is frozen you know something
is wrong because usually a very talkative lad
and look at this ludwig played pawn to d3
and that's a knight so mikko brings the
bishop out to defend the square but ludwig
takes a night for the cost of just a pawn
i don't think mikko is at the point where she
understands point values we talked about it
and she kind of hit me with the blah
blah blah blah blah which i understand
um i feel like that's the first thing a bot should
know how to do is quick accounting that isn't what
we use calculators and everything for yeah he's
a unique unique bot got it and well ludwig's
popping his head so i think he feels pretty good
there's a check made in one threat on the f7 pawn
you think mika will not see this no no oh she
will probably bring out a knight or a pawn i don't
think she will see the checkmate and sometimes we
forget that it's not just the palm center text
if you push the pawn thinking it's under attack
the queen still goes to that very square that's
an easy thing to make a mistake about because
you think the queen's capturing the pawn but no
it's trying to go there with checkmate that's the
bigger thing i mean shoes oh yeah oh and um it's
game one hey hey still better than excuse me bad
winner bad winner ludwig is bad winner okay how
about this i will play slower i'll play slower and
uh i'll try to use i'll try to think
i'm not going to show you the shirt
cutie made me wear it i don't want to wear it i've
been asking him to change his pants for the last
three days i can't make him do anything that's not
that's crazy it's that work from home loungewear
he can just chill in the same sweatpants
for oh my gosh oh gosh my freaking awesome
girlfriend i can't read all the fine
print but that's she's a bit crazy she
has anger issues but she's a perfect mixture
of sweetheart and warrior i love her so much
she's my life flirt with me and you'll be dead or
something like that have you put that to memory
or did you just read that very quickly okay i
made the shirt i wrote it oh okay got it got it
i'm just kidding it's from amazon
i just read it really quickly
oh i couldn't even i could barely see it i just
saw the really large print and that's about it
all right and they're off yeah they're obviously
loud puts a knight in c6 to protect the pawn e5 so
now we'll see if kodmiko goes for bishop c4 the
italian game and yes she does staring at the pawn
on f7 potentially for attack but i think ludwig
his experience here he knows how to handle this
miko said she was going to use her brain this
game is what she learned from the last game
she said i'm going to use my brain this game
the weird thing to hear from a bot brain bot
really don't go hand together so well but i
think it's working this new tactic is working
and let's seems hyped he seems really
into this position but he hasn't moved
what does this love face say to you
telling a story he's telling a story
at the end of the day chess.com's motive is to get
more attention to chess and their website which
is done by getting big people on but big people
don't always have the time but they're big for a
reason it's because they put time on another thing
please please don't be too hard on contestants who
aren't able to put as much time as like tofu in
the chess it is not a flaw or a mistake it is
just because they don't really know what
they're signing up for i think pogchamp
should be just fun and it's not our fault
that ludwig is so sweaty and he tries so hard
okay does he yes he plays chess every single
night on an alt account he has an alt chess
account not this ludwig ogren one he literally
has an alt check don't spill his secrets i'm going
to because mikko just wants to have fun but why
can't you have fun and try hard at the same time
no absolutely not okay i'm just trying to you
know stick out for lud skywalker over here no
no no i just think you know some of us some
of us we just want to have fun we just want to
have a good time myth myth is one of them you
know maybe i'm just defending being bad whoa
whoa come on don't don't be so hard
on yourself you approved so much
during part two well yeah well i didn't get
invited back to pog3 so it wasn't my decision
super rude of you me what did i do you didn't
ask me no we didn't have a conversation about
this they told me i didn't have 500 000 subs
on youtube so they wouldn't invite me back
oh well i don't even have a youtube page so then
they told me they'd invite me to commentary so
i wouldn't call them sexist again and i said
okay oh okay well now you're here never mind
your time won't call you sexist twitch i
mean chess i'll still call twitch sexist
oh gosh and well ludwig looking more serious
he's biting his nails i'm just going to
keep developing like this
idea
i understand that what happened he just
took my bishop right then maybe i'll take
hmm took my bishop that's okay it's okay
it's fine she's not gonna take one of
those pawns maybe i can go she should but she's
trying to figure out a way to get active here
i'll just take this there
she goes it's fine well done
it's very pensive she's really thinking hard
here she's really thinking about her moves here i
this is she's down a minute on ludwig
and he's going fast he's having no mercy
as soon as she just curses out of nowhere and
well we saw what happened with charlie yesterday
against mr beast when charles started playing a
little too quickly mr beast found great ideas to
even trap charles queen so you have to be careful
you don't get overconfident but tonight right now
took on c5 and ludwig now sees that the queen
can go gobble up that night yeah this is
overwhelming right now oh she didn't
move her bishop her bishop is free
right does she create a threat but lovely true
i miss that nobody can just take well it happens
right because you think about the bishop was
hanging a second ago and now f4 is just like
maybe we'll tunnel on that bishop but the queen
needs to be taken care of first and larry can
just take this pawn on f4 and continue
with the attack against the white king
so yeah it looks really good for
ludwig he obviously won the first game
he's the much higher rated player very
experienced and i actually didn't see any
games from code miko in the last few
days after her match against charlie
so maybe she wasn't practicing or maybe
she was getting coaching that i didn't see
yeah i'm not sure if she's doing any off-stream
coaching well you could have lent a hand yeah i
should have as a friend i should have pitched in
a little more this could be on you but she was
banned for a very long time oh so well that's not
good that's not going to help yourself yeah yeah
i think she needs your coaching though well we'll
set up a time we'll get in there this is why chess
and i hate to break it to a lot of people
watching this is why chess does not equal iq
i know that miko is smarter than ludwig
1 000 million percent but then when people are
like oh he's she's bad at chess so she's stupid
oh gosh get off your high school she moves to
e1 she's a genius yeah those takes are terrible
snap intakes are terrible so it's mate let's
thank you no it's got the thinking music on
all right fun little uh pin here oh
he's got this a kitty is a checkman on the next
move if the king goes there if he brings his
knight in wow this is such a sick checkmate oh
wow yeah i see that what a dope mate yep okay
and we returned with the players
lovely congrats on the 2-0 score there
and first question is when's the last time you
change your sweatpants okay can cutie cinderella
never be accepted to do commentary again if she's
gonna harass me and talk on me i changed my sweats
i changed them oh okay finally oh finally
mine arse i worked out this morning and i
was wearing a dirty shirt for a workout what am i
supposed to wear a button down now for workouts no
it was like three days old
dirty covered in hot sauce
yeah no it's a working man's shirt i'm a
working man i wear a working man's shirt
you play video games on a computer not
even i react to stuff it's different
okay and i and i broke a sweat so look at
this so i'm it's hard to work stressed him out
i was stressed out on the italian game really yeah
you played a pretty tight italian at the start and
i didn't know what i was doing no way are you
being sarcastic no being dead ass and then you
made like eight blunders then i was fine but until
then i was pretty nervous yeah amigo are you going
to do any lessons maybe with cutie cinderella you
need more lessons mikko i would love to do more
lessons with you can you teach me how to beat
ludwig well i can't even beat ludwig might take
an army mikko all right can we put both take down
one two combined maybe if it's parts which in this
case i don't know just frankly i mean chess.com
does have the four player modes so maybe me miko
and hess against you ludwig well maybe 2v2
me and has first youtube boys versus girls
i am i for sure am i just think really i love
this boys versus girls idea i would love to latch
on that tess would you rather be on our team
or his team everything's great i'm gonna teach
you something called the stonewall miko what's
that no that's what you should say gotta get
over the stone we love the stonewall you've been
playing it for a year just do anything else say
just try something it's always stonewall
this mission taught me this occasionally
you want to talk about you want to talk about
that anyway anything else you want to add
well why am i getting throwback to me i don't
want to get involved in this situation here
in fact cutie cinderella we are co-commentators
we're completely equal here anything you'd like to
say to ludwig he um as an adult man uh he still
wets the bed and i want you guys to know that
wait what all right see you guys later
oh i don't know how to leave the
call i don't want to leave the place
i figured it out i figured
out i'm leaving i'm leaving
bye